an equilibrium constant can be
calculated from experimentally measured
concentrations or partial pressures of
reactants and products at equilibrium
as an example let's look at the reaction
where n2o4 in the gaseous state turns
into 2no2 also in the gaseous state and
let's say we do an experiment and we
allow this reaction to come to
equilibrium and the temperature is 100
degrees celsius
and at equilibrium the concentration of
no2 is .0172 molar and the concentration
of n2o4 is
.00140 molar
to calculate the equilibrium constant
for this reaction at 100 degrees celsius
we first need to write the equilibrium
constant expression
we can write the equilibrium constant
expression by using the balanced
equation we start by writing the
equilibrium constant which is symbolized
by k and since we're dealing with
concentrations we're calculating kc
and kc is equal to
we do products over reactants so this
would be the concentration of no2
and since there's a coefficient of 2 in
front of no2 this is the concentration
of no2 raised to the second power
divided by the concentration of our
reactant
n2o4 and since there's an implied 1 in
front of n2o4 this is the concentration
of n2o4 raised to the first power
next we plug in our equilibrium
concentrations so the equilibrium
concentration of no2
is
.0172 so let's plug that in so this is
equal to .0172
squared
divided by the equilibrium concentration
of
n2o4 which was .00140
so we plug that in as well so point zero
zero one four
zero
when we solve this we get that k c is
equal to point
two
one one
and this is at one hundred
celsius it's important to always give
the temperature when you're giving a
value for an equilibrium constant
because an equilibrium constant is only
constant for a particular reaction at a
particular temperature
and it's also important to note that k
doesn't the equilibrium constant doesn't
have any units so we would just say that
kc is equal to 0.211 at 100 degrees
celsius for this particular reaction
let's calculate the equilibrium constant
for another reaction in this reaction
carbon dioxide reacts with hydrogen gas
to produce carbon monoxide and h2o and
since everything is in the gaseous state
experimentally it's easier to work with
partial pressures than is to work with
concentrations so instead of calculating
kc we're going to calculate kp where the
p stands for pressure so we're trying to
find kp at 500 kelvin for this reaction
to help us find kp we're going to use an
ice table where i stands for the initial
partial pressure in atmospheres c stands
for the change in the partial pressure
also in atmospheres and e is the
equilibrium partial pressure let's say
that a mixture of carbon dioxide
hydrogen gas and h2o are placed in a
previously evacuated flask and allowed
to come to equilibrium at 500 kelvin and
let's say the initial measured partial
pressures are 4.10 atmospheres for
carbon dioxide 1.80 atmospheres for
hydrogen gas
and 3.20 atmospheres for h2o and since
we didn't add any carbon monoxide in the
beginning the initial partial pressure
of that would be zero
and after the reaction comes to
equilibrium we measure the partial
pressure of h2o to be
3.40 atmospheres so that's why we have
3.40
in the equilibrium part on the ice table
under h2o
so the initial partial pressure of h2o
is 3.20 atmospheres and the equilibrium
partial pressure is 3.40
so h2o has increased in partial
pressures we can go ahead in here and
write plus x for an increase in the
partial pressure of h2o and
3.20 plus x must be equal to
four zero so x is equal to point
two zero so the partial pressure of
water increased by point two zero and we
could either write plus x in here on our
ice table or we could just write plus
.20
now that we know the change in the
partial pressure for h2o we can use this
information to fill out the rest of our
ice table for example the mole ratio of
carbon monoxide to h2o is one to one so
if we gained plus 0.20 for h2o we're
also going to gain plus
0.20 for carbon monoxide and if we're
gaining for our two products here the
net reaction is moving to the right to
increase the amount of products which
means we're losing reactants and we can
figure out by how much by looking at the
mole ratios again so for both of our
reactants we have ones as coefficients
in the balanced equation so if it's plus
x for both of our products it must be
minus x for both of our reactants and
since x is 0.20 it'd be minus
for the change in the partial pressure
for both of our reactants
therefore the equilibrium partial
pressure of carbon dioxide would be 4.10
minus 0.20 which is three 3.90
and for h2 it'd be 1.80 minus 0.20 which
is 1.60
and for carbon monoxide we started off
with zero and we gained positive 0.20
therefore the equilibrium partial
pressure is
0.20
so as the net reaction moved to the
right we lost some of our reactants and
we gained some of our products until the
reaction reached equilibrium and we got
our equilibrium partial pressures and at
equilibrium
the forward reaction the rate of the
forward reaction is equal to the rate of
the reverse reaction and therefore these
equilibrium partial pressures remain
constant
now that we know our equilibrium partial
pressures we're ready to calculate the
equilibrium constant kp
so we need to write an equilibrium
constant expression so kp is equal to we
think about products over reactants and
for our products we would have the
partial pressure of carbon monoxide and
since the coefficient is a one in front
of carbon monoxide in the balanced
equation it'd be the partial pressure of
carbon monoxide raised to the first
power
times the partial pressure of our other
product which is h2o and once again the
coefficient is a one so that's the
partial pressure raised to the first
power
all of this is divided by we think about
our reactants next and they both have
coefficients of one in the balanced
equation so it would be the partial
pressure of carbon dioxide
times the partial pressure of hydrogen
gas
the partial pressures in our equilibrium
constant expression are the equilibrium
partial pressures which we can get from
the ice table so the equilibrium partial
pressure of carbon monoxide is 0.20 the
equilibrium partial pressure of h2o is
3.40
we can plug in the equilibrium partial
pressures for carbon dioxide and the
equilibrium partial pressure for
hydrogen gas as well
here we have the equilibrium partial
pressures plugged into our equilibrium
constant expression and when we solve
this we get that kp is equal to
0.11
at 500
kelvin